Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Noch vor 200 Jahren hätte wohl kaum ein Mensch geglaubt, dass es so etwas wie die Dinosaurier
wirklich gegeben haben könnte. Also Tiere mit einer Größe von 18m. Und genauso
wenig glauben wir heute, dass es einen Riesenaffen wie King Kong geben kann.
Aber die Frage ist, stimmt das wirklich? Also
ist ein mehrere Meter großer Affe vielleicht
denkbar und wenn ja, würde er so wie in den
Filmen aussehen oder vielleicht ganz anders?
Und wie würde der eigentlich leben?
Um das zu klären, beleuchtet wird die Frage
wieder von zwei Seiten. Für das Fiktionale
und Filmische haben wir zum zweiten Mal unseren
liebsten Filmnerd Alper von Cinema Strikes
Back dabei und um die Wissenschaft kümmert
sich heute die Biologin und Primatenforscherin Anne-Céline Granjon.
Die wissenschaftliche Arbeit von Anne-Céline ist Kacke. Also wirklich. Denn für ihre Doktorarbeit
hat sie die Hinterlassenschaften von Berggorillas gezählt und vermessen, um zu schauen, wie
viele es von denen noch gibt. Dafür war sie
monatelang in afrikanischen Dschungeln unterwegs.
Anne-Céline hat ein Faible für klassische
Musik und historische Tänze und ist - na klar -
gern draußen wandern, um die Natur
zu erkunden.
Anne-Céline, schön, dass Du da bist, freue
mich. - Hallo!
Lass uns doch mal schauen, wie groß eigentlich echte Gorillas werden können.
Das hängt davon ab, von welcher Art wir reden.
Es gibt nämlich zwei. Die Westlichen Gorillas leben in Zentralafrika, nahe dem Golf von Guinea
und haben typischerweise eine rote
Kappe auf dem Kopf.
Die Östlichen Gorillas leben in Ostafrika,
im Grenzgebiet der Demokratischen Republik Kongo,
Uganda und Ruanda. Die haben typischerweise
ein dickes Fell. Diese sind auch die, die
wir typischerweise bei einer Google-Suche
von wilden Gorillas finden würden.
Und welche von beiden Arten ist nun größer?
Die Östlichen Gorillas. Da können die Männchen knapp 2m erreichen, die Westlichen Gorillas wiederum nur 1,80m.
Wenn ich bei der Google-Suche jetzt drauf
schaue würde ich sagen, dass King Kong eher
ein Östlicher Gorilla ist. Auch wenn der
natürlich viel größer als 2m ist. Wie groß
King Kong genau ist, dass weiß ich jetzt nicht. Da muss uns Cinema Strikes Back aushelfen. Alper, gib uns doch mal einen Überblick.
Wie groß Kong wirklich ist, ist eigentlich nur schwer zu beantworten, wenn überhaupt. Denn schon im ersten Film „King Kong und
die weiße Frau“ variiert seine Größe
von Szene zu Szene. Am kleinsten war wohl
„Little Kong“, King Kongs Sohn. Er ist
nämlich keine 4m groß und auch in Peter Jacksons
„King Kong“ ist er mit 7m eher
klein. Er ist schon deutlich größer in „Kong Skull Island“,
mit 31m. Aber da ist er noch im Wachstum. In „Godzilla vs. Kong" soll er sage und schreibe 102m groß sein.
Tausend Dank Alper. Das heißt, wir haben
eine ganz große Auswahl zwischen 7m und 102m. 102m können wir ausschließen, oder?
Das ist Quatsch. Aber wenn wir uns auf die 7m konzentrieren, das ist ja immer noch mehr
als dreimal so viel wie die normalen Östlichen Gorillas. Hätte King Kong eine Chance gehabt, so groß zu werden?
Also es gab auf jeden Fall einen Riesenaffen.
Der letzte Fund ist etwa 100.000 Jahre her
und man geht davon aus, dass Gigantopithecus
bis zu 3m hoch war und 500kg schwer. Ganz genau kann man das leider nicht sagen,
weil wir leider bis jetzt nur Kieferfragmente und Zähne gefunden haben.
Aber 3m ist schon ziemlich groß. Stell Dir
vor, Du hast so ein Riesentier vor Dir.
Auf jeden Fall. Also würde mir vollkommen
reichen, um da schnell abzuhauen.
Aber das heißt ja schon mal, dass die Natur
Affen im Riesenformat zustande bringt.
Und das Überraschende daran ist, es ist gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich. Heute sind wir überrascht
davon, weil große Tiere eher die Ausnahme
sind. Aber wenn wir uns die Vergangenheit
anschauen, dann waren Riesensäugetiere eigentlich über der ganzen Welt verbreitet.
Und da reden wir nicht nur von Elefanten,
Giraffen oder Nashörnern, sondern auch von
Riesenkängurus oder Faultieren. Und natürlich Riesenaffen.
Das heißt, aus evolutionsbiologischer Sicht
wäre so eine Spezies wie King Kong tatsächlich denkbar?
Na möglich ist natürlich vieles. Ich halte
es aber eher für unwahrscheinlich, weil es
auch Nachteile hat groß zu sein.
Ja, ich kann das bestätigen. Klein sein hat
auch manchmal Vorteile. Was sind denn die
Vor- und Nachteile von Tieren in bestimmten Größen?
Wenn die Umweltbedingungen gut sind und die Tiere wachsen können, dann hat die Größe
eher Vorteile. Große Tiere sind natürlich
besser vor Raubtieren geschützt.
Sie können auch vielmehr Nahrung aufnehmen, auch energiearme Nahrung und sie können auch
größere Distanzen zurücklegen, um Futter
zu suchen.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu den Nachteilen. Je
größer eine Art wird, desto länger braucht
sie, um überhaupt Nachkommen bekommen zu können. Sie muss ja erstmal wachsen.
Gorillas zum Beispiel sind erst nach sieben bis zehn Jahren fortpflanzungsfähig. Hunde nach einem
Jahr und Mücken nach zwei Wochen. Das heißt, in den zehn Jahren, die es braucht um eine
Gorilla Generation zu machen, gibt es schon
zehn Hunde Generationen und 260 Mückengenerationen.
Also wenn es eine Umweltveränderung gibt,
zum Beispiel eine Nahrungsquelle bricht ab,
der Klimawandel oder ein neuer Fressfeind
kommt rein, dann haben in der Zeit, wo Gorillas
eine Generation produzieren, die Mücken 260-mal die Chance, eine genetische Mutation zu
bekommen, die ihnen dann hilft.
Kurz gesagt: große Tiere reagieren langsamer
auf Änderungen, ein bisschen so wie mit der
Titanic und dem Eisberg. Große Arten lassen
sich nur langsam auf einem neuen „genetischen Kurs“ bringen.
King Kong hat ja noch ein zweites Problem.
Wenn jetzt eine Umweltveränderung oder eine
Krise kommt kann er nicht weg, da er auf einer Insel ist.
Richtig. Und dass macht die Ressourcen natürlich deutlich knapper. Deswegen beobachten wir
in der Regel auf Inseln, das bei großen Arten
eher eine Verzwergung stattfindet. Zum Beispiel
gibt es das Inselzwergmammut, das kaum größer als 1m war.
Ein Mammut von 1m? Ja, okay, krass.
Es gibt auch heutzutage auf der indonesischenInsel Borneo, den Borneo-Zwergelefant.
Der ist definitiv 1m kleiner, als die normalen Asiatischen Elefanten.
Das heißt, rein evolutionär spricht jetzt
nicht so viel für einen Riesenaffen, wie
King Kong. Aber Anne-Céline. Wir sind hier
bei Science vs. Fiction. Wir müssen einen
Workaround finden, dass das trotzdem klappt.
Was ist denn, wenn diese Größe jetzt gar
nicht die Spezies betrifft, sondern nur King
Kong als Individuum? Also irgendein Vorfall,
den es auf der Insel gab. Die Lebewesen dort sind ausnahmslos alle groß.
Na gut, dann lass uns mal kurz wild spekulieren.
Wenn seine Eltern schon sehr groß waren,
sagen wir die Größe von Gigantopithecus,
etwa 3m, dann könnte vielleicht eine Krankheit oder ein Gen-Defekt dazu führen, dass er
doppelt so groß wird. Da kommen wir auf 6m,
Aber dafür bräuchten wir ein paar mehr Informationen über King Kong. Die kriegen wir ran, da können
wir ja einfach Alper fragen. Du hast doch
bestimmt ein paar Nerd-Facts für uns?
Man erfährt mehr über Kong und seine ganze Spezies in einem Comic, dass die Vorgeschichte
erzählt. „Skull Island, the Birth of Kong“.
Seine Spezies soll ganze Jahrtausende auf
Skull Island gelebt haben, bis die natürlichen Feinde an die Erdoberfläche kamen. Die Skull Crawler,
auf Deutsch Schädel-Kriecher. Sie
löschten alle Vertreter der Spezies aus,
selbst Kongs Eltern, kurz nachdem Kong zur
Welt kam.
Anhand der Knochen weiß man, dass die schon ziemlich groß gewesen sein sollen. Wie groß
die aber waren und ob Kong nicht eventuell
ein ausgesprochen großer Vertreter seiner
Spezies ist, dass weiß man nicht so genau.
Im „Monsterverse“ ist er schließlich
auch das einzige, lebende Exemplar dieser
Spezies, das je gesichtet wurde.
Also eine Krankheit oder einen Gen-Defekt
können wir schon mal ausschließen.
Dann muss es ja auf der Insel irgendeinen anderen Vorteil geben, dass die Tiere da so groß werden können.
Also es gibt schon ein Pendant zur Inselverzwergung,
den sogenannten Inselgigantismus. Da werden Arten eher größer, zum Beispiel um sich
gegen Fressfeinde zu wehren oder wegen der Konkurrenz
Und auf Skull Island hat King Kong auf jeden
Fall jede Menge Konkurrenz.
Und zur Verteidigung hätte seine Art vielleicht größer werden können. Allerdings nur, wenn
die anderen Arten damals auch noch nicht so groß waren und sie gemeinsam gewachsen wären.
Damit man immer einen Vorteil hat, ein bisschen
größer als die anderen Arten zu sein.
Wenn im Gegenteil eine Rieseneidechse schon von Anfang an auf der Insel war, dann wäre
es für ein Tier von der Größe eines Gorillas
eigentlich eher vorteilhaft gewesen, kleiner
zu werden, um sich besser verstecken zu können.
Okay, schade. Also auch hier eher schlechte Chancen für einen Riesenaffen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt einfach mal davon ausgehen, dass wir einen King Kong haben.
Der ist 7m groß, das ist jetzt gesetzt. Was würde das denn für seine Lebensweise bedeuten?
Er hätte schon vier Probleme, die ich sehe,
mit denen er sich auseinandersetzen sollte.
Es gibt ja viele andere Pflanzenfresser auf
der Insel. Und ich würde mir schon vorstellen, dass sie sich ziemlich in die Quere kommen.
Pflanzenfresser verteilen zwar die Samen und düngen den Boden mit ihren Wanderungen, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob die Pflanzen wirklich
schnell genug wieder wachsen können, um wirklich
längerfristig so viele Pflanzenfresser zu
ernähren.
Und das war nämlich auch das Problem bei
Gigantopithecus. Der war auch ein Pflanzenfresser
und hat im Wald gelebt. Aber mit dem Klimawandel sind die Wälder, wo er gelebt hat,
teilweise so sehr geschrumpft, dass er nicht mehr genug Nahrung für sich gefunden hat.
Und er ist dann deswegen aus gestorben…
...Vermutlich.
Und King Kong hat noch mal viel mehr Appetit. Was müsste der denn dann pro Tag wegsnacken?
Unglaublich viel! Wenn wir es zum Beispiel
mit einem Gorilla vergleichen. Ein erwachsenes
Gorillamännchen frisst ungefähr 30 kg Nahrung pro Tag. Das ist ungefähr 1/8tel seines Körpergewichts.
King Kong ist ja ungefähr 2 ½-mal größer.
Das heißt aber auch2 ½-mal breiter und
2½-mal dicker. Das ist insgesamt 15-mal schwerer. Wir würden ungefähr zu einem Gewicht von
3000 kg kommen. Wenn er sich ungefähr wie ein Gorilla ernährt, dann würde es bedeuten,
dass er 400 kg Nahrung zu sich nehmen soll. Und zwar jeden Tag.
Wenn ich das mal für mich überlege, ich
müsste 1/8tel meines Körpergewichts essen,
dass wären 9 kg Salat jeden Tag. Wie wäre
das dann bei Euch? Wieviel müsste bei Euch
auf dem Teller landen? Schreibt das mal in
die Kommentare.
Und King Kong müsste dazu noch ziemlich umherwandern. In der Natur sind schon die Gorillas ungefähr
zwölf Stunden am Tag auf Nahrungssuche.
Und da ist die Frage, ob Skull Island überhauptgroß genug wäre. Also wenn man da mal so schaut, es gibt Karten auf Filmpostern und
da sind dann diese Entfernungs-Skalen dabei. Wenn man das so grob hochrechnet, kommt man
auf so 1.000km² Fläche für die Insel. Würde
das überhaupt reichen?
Da können wir eine kleine Rechnung aufmachen und die echten Gorillas als Vergleich nehmen.
Es gibt etwa 1.000 Berggorillas in zwei Gebiete verteilt, Bwindi und Virunga. Zusammen sind
es etwa 800km². Das ist etwa die Größe
von Hamburg. Das bedeutet, dass jeder Gorilla
etwa einem knappen Quadratkilometer für sich hat.
Wenn wir einen Kong nehmen, der ungefähr
15-mal so viel Nahrung braucht, dann würde
das bedeuten, dass er in etwa 12 km² Fläche braucht.
Das würde auf Skull Island ja gut hinhauen.
Wenn wir 1.000km² zur Verfügung haben.
Aber wir reden hier nur von einem Kong. Um
überhaupt da zu sein, braucht er Eltern,
Großeltern und so weiter. Kurz gesagt bräuchte er eine Population, durch die er entstanden ist.
Und wenn wir Skull Island mit 1.000 km²
nehmen, dann würde es eigentlich nur für 100 Kongs reichen.
Wie groß müsste Skull Island dann sein, damit so eine Population von 1.000 Tieren irgendwie funktionieren würde?
Also wenn wir 1.000 nehmen, wie die Berggorillas, was schon knapp ist muss ich trotzdem sagen,
dann würde es ungefähr die Größe von Jamaika brauchen.
Wow, also viel, viel, viel größer, als wir
es auf den Postern oder in den Filmen sehen.
Also zu futtern bekommt King Kong nicht so richtig viel und dann kommen auch noch diese körperlichen Probleme dazu.
Richtig! King Kong läuft ja meist aufrecht
wie wir. Aber die Schwerkraft zieht ihn natürlich nach unten und mit seinen 7m Größe würde
seine Wirbelsäule enorm viel Kraft ausgesetzt werden. Das würden seine Knochen vielleicht
nicht mal aushalten können. Und selbst wenn sie das tun, dann hätte er wahrscheinlich
Haltungsschäden, Bandscheibenvorfälle oder zumindest Rückenschmerzen.
King Kong wäre also ein kompletter Pflegefall.
Das würde vielleicht funktionieren, wenn
er zum Beispiel viel breitere Knochen hätte
und auch breitere Muskeln. Da könnte es vielleicht passen.
Aber am besten wäre es eigentlich,
wenn er auf allen Vieren laufen würde.
Dafür bräuchte er wiederum ein fehlendes Polster an den Füßen.
So wie bei Elefanten?
Richtig. Da würde sich mir aber die Frage
stellen, wenn er auf allen Vieren läuft wie würden dann seine Hände aussehen? Sind diese dann überhaupt noch als Hände benutzbar?
Kann er damit noch greifen, wenn alles so dick ist?
Würde auf jeden Fall super komisch
und anders aussehen, als wir es jetzt im Film angezeigt bekommen.
Auf jeden Fall!
Und jetzt kommt die dritte Herausforderung.
Sein Herz müsste eine unglaublich starke
Pumpleistung bringen, um alle Organe mit Sauerstoff zu versorgen. Gorillas können jetzt schon
nur relativ kurz auf Höchstleistung sein,
zum Beispiel klettern oder kämpfen. Ein King Kong
würde wahrscheinlich einfach immer außer
Atem sein.
Okay, also nichts mit „ich verprügle eine
Urzeit-Echse oder klettre auf das Empire State Building hoch.
So wie das in den Filmen immer so spektakulär aussieht.
Eher nicht.
Außer seiner Art hat sich auch daran angepasst.
Zum Beispiel die Giraffen. Giraffen sind auch bis zu 6m hoch und die schaffen das irgendwie,
das Blut bis zum Kopf zirkulieren zu lassen.
Dafür haben sie spezielle Blutgefäße und
auch spezielle Ventilen in den Arterien im
Hals, damit das Blut hochkommt.
Damit hätte King Kong zwar ein großes Herz
und einen sehr hohen Blutdruck, aber da wäre relativ gesund.
Und das King Kong ein großes Herz hat wissen wir, zumindest für die Frauen.
Und lass uns mal zum letzten Punkt kommen. Die Hitze.
King Kong wird in der Regel mit
einem ziemlich dicken Fell dargestellt, ein
bisschen so wie bei den Berggorillas.
Aber die Berggorillas wohnen in den Bergen
von etwa 3.000m Höhe. Da kann es ziemlich kalt werden – bis zu 0ºC. Und deswegen
brauchen Sie ein dickes Fell
Auf Skull Island würde ich mir eher vorstellen,
dass da so typische Tropentemperaturen sind, 23 ºC bis 30 ºC. Da wäre er mit so einem
dicken Fell einfach viel zu warmgehalten.
Da würde einfach helfen, ein viel dünneres
Feld zu haben, wie zum Beispiel bei den Westlichen Gorillas. Trotzdem wäre das Problem, wenn
er so groß ist, dann hat er auch viel mehr
Zellen, die Hitze produzieren. Und King Kong
selbst hat wenig Oberfläche, um diese Hitze
rauszukriegen.
Das haben wir schon mal so ähnlich besprochen, nämlich in unserer Ant-Man-Folge. Die verlinke ich Euch mal hier oben.
Nur bei King Kong ist es genau umgekehrt.
Also Kong produziert zu viel Hitze und müsste halt ein dünnes Fell haben oder irgendeinen
Mechanismus, um diese Hitze wieder abzugeben.
Fassen wir zusammen: Ein King Kong von über 100m
Größe ist totaler Quatsch. Auch wenn
es natürlich im Film cool aussieht und die
kleinste Variante mit 7m ist nur dann plausibel, wenn es auf Skull Island einen evolutionären
Druck gegeben hat, damit er wachsen muss. Und funktioniert natürlich auch nur dann,
wenn er sich entsprechend angepasst hätte.
Fest steht aber, dass King Kong in echt nicht
so wie in den Filmen aussehen würde.
Vielen Dank fürs erklären…
…gerne!
Danke geht raus an Alper von Cinema Strikes Back,
der sich für uns durch diese ganzen
King Kong-Filme gewühlt hat. Flitzt doch
mal rüber zu deren Kanal und lasst ein paar
Grüße in den Kommentaren da und vergesst
bitte nicht diesen Kanal hier zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder. Ich würde
mich freuen, bis dahin!
(Ich guck mal ganz schnell, was wir jetzt
als nächstes drehen. Welche Position)
(Wir sind im Dschungel!)
(Gefährlich und wild! Und gleich kommt ein Schädelschlüpfer.)
(Ich befinde mich heut echt in einer Friesen-Situation.
Regen die ganze Zeit, guckt mal meine Haare. Ich brauche einen Akku-Fön.)